is islam innately misogynistic
the answer to that unfortunately is a
clear cut yes if someone wants to quote
aspects of the islamic discourse
aspects of the islamic
jewish prudential tradition and
juxtapose it with the western discourses
especially here we're talking about
second wave feminism and expect islam to
correspond with those they'll be utterly
and bitterly disappointed because
clearly we believe our system is
superior
welcome to episode 140 of the michaela
peterson podcast i'm mikayla peterson
this episode was intense to say the
least it's an opposing views on islam
i had muhammad hijab on one side an
author and philosopher interested in
political philosophy and comparative
religion and i had the pleasure of
speaking to ayan hirsi ali an author
scholar and former politician best known
for her activism against women's
treatment in islam
i'm incredibly honored to be able to
host these kind of conversations and to
be able to speak to two sides of
contentious subjects i'm never happy
when one side goes after the other side
and attacks them personally rather than
attacking their ideas i left the
supposing views kind of freaked out and
fairly aggravated to be honest but i
haven't edited anything because i think
it's best to show what and how everyone
said things regardless of how
uncomfortable it was
if you enjoy this content or learn
something please consider subscribing
before we jump into a somewhat stressful
podcast this episode was brought to you
by nordvpn nordvpn is the fastest vpn in
the world maybe you already knew that
but there's more nordvpn helps protect
you against all sorts of things
for example bandwidth throttling from
internet providers who will slow down
your internet towards the end of your
contract hoping to force an upgrade
did you know that they can do that nasty
but true nordvpn encrypts your data and
you can get content from anywhere in the
world with it they are without a doubt
the best vpn in the game and i've been
using vpns since forever because
canadian netflix sucks now i'm in land
of the free thank goodness but i still
use a vpn
they have a new exclusive offer for my
listeners grab your nord vpn deal today
over at nordvpn.com
tmpp or use promo code tmpp the podcast
acronym for a huge discount off their
premium plans an extra free month and a
secret bonus gift all with nordvpn's 30
day money back guarantee
enjoy the episode
[Music]
ion thank you very much for joining me
on my podcast
michaela thank you very much for having
me we've been trying to do this for a
long time i'm glad that we're finally
doing it
i'm so glad this is going to be very
very interesting so
i'm happy about it i hope so yeah okay
let's get started so we're doing we're
doing a podcast on islam today
and i have a number of questions so i'm
just going to get right into it if that
actually no let's start off with if
anyone doesn't know who you are can you
give a brief background about who you
are and what it is you do
so my name is ayan hershey ali i was
born in somalia and i lived in
saudi arabia in ethiopia in kenya and
when i was 22 years old
i went to the netherlands and i think
i'm famous or infamous
for leaving islam
and
having lived in
these african and middle eastern
countries after i arrived in the
netherlands
having
made a journey that's not just
geographical not just physical
but intellectual
and so when i got acquainted with the
norms and values
of the west such as freedom equality the
rule of law
uh women's rights
um i thought that those values and those
principles were superior to the ones
that i was raised in
i was raised within the culture of islam
and in a tribal society
and so
i would say in a nutshell that's my
story
okay great
okay so i'm going to start off with
with
what what was your experience and this
is kind of a broad question but what was
your experience with islam like
well in the early years
before i was 20 years old i would say
it was
mundane
we were not extremely religious
we identified ourselves as muslims
prayed five times a day when we could
and all that
but
we didn't really have the fundamentalist
fanatical strains that we see later when
in the 1980s when i was a teenager
there were teachers who came to our
schools in our neighborhoods
who are
propagating this radical strain
and um i joined them i i fell for it
what attracted me i think was just the
um
the clarity that they offered you know
you've got
a whole list of
hear the things that are forbidden in
islam here are the things that are
permitted and all you have to do is just
abide by these rules and you're a good
person
um and then once i started actually
trying to abide by those rules
i found out how extremely difficult it
was and then later on in my life when i
came to the netherlands and i saw people
who are actually good people honest
people people who tell the truth
and who do things in ways that are very
productive in their relationships with
other human beings and within the world
that's when i started to reflect on
islam
both in the sense that i was raised the
way
we were passive muslims and later on
when we became i became
an active fanatical believer
okay um were the people you were seeing
in the netherlands were these other
religious people like christianity or
atheist agnostic or just in general
uh many of them were christians so when
i first arrived at the asylum seeker
center most of the people who
volunteered
to help asylum seekers refugees
they did it through their churches so
they were christians
and the christianity that i saw that was
practiced in the netherlands was a very
appealing christianity people were
actually
i thought very generous very tolerant
uh for instance even though they
volunteered to help us as non-christians
they didn't demand that we convert to
christianity they didn't preach their
religion they didn't impose on us in
that way at all
um
and and i thought that was interesting
because
when uh i started to become an active
muslim
and abide by these rules of
you know the permitted and the forbidden
and all that i really wanted to be a
good muslim one of the things that our
teachers were telling us was
you have to go and convert
non-muslims
and uh and i thought it was interesting
when i came to the netherlands that
these christians
uh were not
imposing
or preaching or proselytizing their
faith
uh they believed that they were just
doing
good for the sake of goodness itself
and so but there were also agnostics
they were atheists uh later on as you
know i i left the asylum seeker center i
went to college i found jobs and
i was surrounded
by the time i left 14 years later by the
time i left the netherlands i was
surrounded more by agnostics and
atheists than christians
okay interesting muhammad hijab welcome
to my podcast welcome
thank you very much for being here this
should be an interesting episode um
before we get started can you give
anyone who doesn't know who you are a
brief background about who you are and
what it is you do
right so
my name is muhammad hijab
much like yourself i'm a i'm a youtuber
i'm the co-founder of the sapiens
institute my academic background is in
politics and history where i've acquired
a postgraduate in that as well
uh islamic studies of course which i've
acquired acquired a postgraduate as well
in addition to applied theology
and currently doing my
my phd in the philosophy of religion i
have to say michaela from the i'll say
here that
unlike the co-guest the ultra
crepidarian academic charlatan
uh co-guest that you have the obsequious
apple polisher for the far right ayan
mcgann which is actually her real name
i'm actually qualified to speak about
that
which we'll be speaking about today
okay
it's quite an intro let's get started
i'm gonna be asking you the same
questions okay
um so first what's your experience with
islam been like i know that's kind of
vague but go for it yeah i mean for me
obviously islam is everything in the
sense that
it defines how my purpose of life my
purpose of life is to worship one god
uh submit my will to one god who is the
creator of the universe
i um
wake up in the morning
thinking of that
go to sleep thinking of that um it gives
me anchorage michaela it gives me moral
uh and existential anchorage it allows
me to live my life in a way which is
meaningful and purposeful
there's a tradition
of the prophet muhammad where he said
wanderers is the affair of the believer
that all of his affair is good and that
is not the case for anyone except for
the believer and that if something good
happens to him he is patient and if
something bad happens to him he is
patient and he's thankful and patient so
in other words for me i think in terms
of my own kind of personal life what it
does is it makes meaning out of pain
because life is full of pain michaela as
we all know it's something that we
cannot avoid and i think having a
framework a religious framework
where the the center is or the central
aspect of it is to worship one god that
there's an eschatological dimension
um that we believe in one god worthy of
worship not a man not you know the
creation but one god we believe in jesus
we believe in the old you know the old
testament prophets
and so on it does give me uh that
stability that i think is uh priceless
um and i have to say that um i i can't
imagine really a life without it you
know so in in a nutshell really what
islam is for me
is is something which not only gives me
meaning and purpose but that if it was
if it was not part of my life
i couldn't imagine
uh what kind of depressed a perpetually
depressed state i would be in
okay um so this is actually this isn't a
question i asked dion because i don't
think it was as relevant but
is there a reason that um you
i wouldn't say chose necessarily but
you're practicing
you're practicing muslim as opposed to a
christian or another religion that
worships one god well look first and
foremost we will object to the fact that
christianity worships one god
christianity both catholicism and
protestantism believe in the the
doctrine of the trinity they believe in
the father the son and the holy spirit
that the father is god the son is god
and the holy spirit is god but there are
not three gods but one god and we say
that that is an unintelligible
proposition that's something that flies
right in the face of reason which is not
possible logically
and that
it's inconceivable it's unintelligible
and it's unpardonable to believe that
any man with a date of birth can be
called god and so jesus christ for us as
muslims is the messiah he is a prophet
sent with wonders and miracles and signs
as the bible correctly says in this
point but we cannot believe and we do
not believe that jesus christ is god or
the son of god we believe that jesus
christ was a mighty messenger sent
from god almighty and that he was a
person who was one of the greatest
people who ever lived on this earth we
believe in from that perspective we're
christians because we follow christ but
we don't believe that jesus christ is
god and in addition i would say we
believe the final prophet muhammad
he had evidences that indicates the
truth and the veracity of his
prophethood and for that reason i to be
honest with you i do believe it's a
choice that everyone does have to make
and this is the reason why i am a muslim
because it's just instinctively
it speaks to me that you have to worship
one god whether you know that the
creator of the heavens and the earth
and that no creation can be god and this
is the the dividing line or the
fundamental difference between muslims
and christians
okay thank you in in your experience
is islam innately misogynistic
the answer to that unfortunately is a
clear cut yes
okay
islam is misogynistic in its approach to
women i know that by saying this
i
offend a lot of people i know that
people's feelings get hurt the feelings
of muslims i know that that
is the case
but setting feelings aside and just
looking objectively as what it is
that islam says about women
and where it positions us
the answer is yes it is misogynistic
and i'll give you a few examples that
would be good yeah
and i think the best example
because it's so factual is the law
sharia law islamic law
islamic law declares
that a woman has to have a male guardian
at all times
that's not required of males
in sharia law a man is permitted to have
four wives
she's not permitted to have four
husbands
in islamic law in sharia law
a woman's testimony in court is worth
half
of that of a man it's not the other way
around
a sister inherits half of what her
brother inherits
wow
and
this goes on and on and i think
because these basic tenets of law
sharia law
when they're implemented and where
they're implemented
you see a huge difference between the
way men and women are treated girls and
boys are treated and i would say that is
misogyny
and because i'm not i'm not that
familiar with
islam is sharia law something that's in
the koran directly
sharia law is derived from the quran and
from the teachings of the prophet
muhammad the prophet muhammad is the
founder of islam
and his legacy is a body of law and
norms
that are implemented where there is a
theocracy like saudi arabia or iran or
any of the other societies that try
to establish
legal systems that are based on islam
so another example on the misogyny side
is
women are expected
to cover their bodies and there is some
kind of discussion on how much of that
in some cases they let you
show their face in the hands
and in extreme cases you have to be
covered from head to toe
and confined to the house
your male guardian
chooses or at least you need his
endorsements to marry someone else and
all of this
is
in uh based in sharia law if you're a
woman and you're not happy in a marriage
it's almost difficult almost impossible
to divorce your husband
uh and
the other way around for a man to
divorce his wife all he has to say is
declare in front of two witnesses three
times that he divorces his wife and
that's done so
on the question is islam misogynistic
i think these facts speak for themselves
uh is islam inherently misogynistic
well first and foremost of course
there are misogyny needs to be defined
because if it's defined definitionally
as it is in the kind of dictionary the
hatred of women then the answer is very
clearly no because the quran very
clearly states
in more than one verse you know in
chapter 3 verse 195
god does not let to waste any action of
any doer among you men or women and that
both of you are from one another that in
chapter 33 verse 35 uh the the believing
men and the believing women and the you
know and so on and it mentions a list of
attributes mentioning men and women
specifically and then says that god has
prepared for them a reward in fact the
quran explicitly mentions that we cannot
have hatred towards any believer because
it's mentioned in chapter 59 of the
quran
god do not put any hatred to the
believers in our hearts and that of
course includes women as well so from
that perspective it's impossible to
postulate it is
impossible to postulate that islam is
misogynistic from that definitional
perspective but what we will say is of
course misogyny is a label that is
used haphazardly and arbitrarily between
people in the west in discourses to mean
different things so of course
neoconservatives or people that are more
right-wing or alt-right are
accused themselves of being misogynistic
to
by third wave feminists and so on and so
it really depends on who is the one
making the claim and what the robust
definition that they have of misogyny is
sometimes that can be ideologically um
kind of inspired in the case of third
wave feminists i would say it certainly
is that's why unfortunately uh even your
father has been accused of misogyny i
mean people in in in the west uh
credible intellectuals and academics
have been accused of misogyny just
because they believe in a traditional uh
value of traditional values of family
system a complementarian family system
and for this reason they're accused of
misogyny so but one has to say this and
i think this is very important michaela
that we believe that there is an
equality of value between men and women
we do believe that there is an equality
of value between men and women the
prophet himself muhammad he said
that certainly men are equal to women in
front of the law that is the general
rule that is a statement of the prophet
muhammad however
we do believe in exceptions and we don't
believe that equality of value means
identicality and roles
and so of course people that are
detracted from the other side
like the academic charlatan ayan mcgann
actually means refugee in the somali
language of course an ironic reminder to
herself
she would say that islam is misogynistic
because of practices such as polygeny
which means that a man can marry more
than one wife and that is a practice
that muslims believe in
all practices such as that muslim men
can marry christian and jewish women of
course that is something that muslim
women cannot do in islam as well
and various other inheritance things or
aspects where there is a differential
there between how men
are treated to women
but we will say that equality of value
does not mean identicality and roles let
me say that one more time equality of
value we believe does not mean
identicality and roles and therefore
just like aristotle said that like
things should be treated like likewise
and that different things should be
treated the same we do believe that
women have a collective female
temperament on certain aspects which
need to be tailored for in legislation
which need to be tailored for in social
and political life
and so therefore if someone wants to use
second wave feministic collectivistic
discourses to try and attack the islamic
narrative then they must first establish
the truthfulness and the objective the
objectiveness of second wave feministic
discourses iron hersey is a feminist
we are opposed to feminism when we say
that feminism has now
almost certainly been cracked open as a
false ideology of course i think what i
think i should add to this in addition
to all that was aforementioned that i
and mcghan
herself was embroiled
in the most embarrassing
of public inquiries if you can call that
that whereby she herself was in a
preligionist relationship she was a
mistress
she was a mistress
to niall ferguson her
husband now and she was doing so at the
dismay
of sue douglas who is his ex-wife
and
with the destabilizing effect of course
the destabilizing effect to his family
to lachlan ferguson to phoenix ferguson
the children of nile ferguson so she
attacks poligini in her books but she
practices in her daily life
and so this is a serious hypocrisy
not just
in that which she does megan iron mcgann
but in that which
she states as well
so the challenge really is and i will
repeat this if someone wants to quote
aspects of the islamic discourse
aspects of the islamic
uh jewish prudential tradition
and juxtapose it with the western
discourses especially here we're talking
about second wave feminism and expect
islam to correspond with those they'll
be utterly and bitterly disappointed
because clearly we believe our system is
superior we believe the system is
failing we believe that
nuclear households are being destroyed
in the west we believe that you've got
it wrong we believe that we've got it
right and so in order to defeat us an
argument you must first argue from first
principles and so yes we do have
differences with western especially
second wave or third wave feministic
discourses but that does not
that does in no way
show indicate
that islam is misogynistic to the
contrary and one last thing i will say
is megan herself
is blissfully ignorant ayan mcgann iron
hersey mcgann
blissfully ignorant of the islamic
tradition the
under-qualified over-confident
ultra-crepidarian academic charlatan
right-wing apple polish-up
obsequious woman that she is doesn't
even know
that in it doesn't even know the basics
of the islamic tradition mentions in her
book heretic in page 77 that we worship
mohammed she doesn't even know the
basics of the religion she makes
squandering mistakes one after the other
about gender in jurisprudence in islam
in her latest book at prey you can see
in page 151
where she
makes a series of
unsubstantiated claims about muslim
women and their rights in islam saying
that their rights can be sold to
strangers and all kinds of nonsense
propositions which have no basis in the
religion of islam so if you really want
to know about women's rights in islam
one has to go to the source and this
ultra crepitarian academic charlatan uh
ayan is is just a failure who's who's
been uh embroi has been
let in by the most unusual types of
affirmative action program to the
neoconservative circles because she has
no academic uh acumen at all
okay
okay
so
i'd i'd like to just keep the rest of
the conversation if we can try and
attack the idea rather than the person
otherwise i'm never going to be able to
have any guests on this show again for
opposing views okay
okay um i have one follow-up question
about what you just said because i think
i understand a bit but um
you talked about
you talked about that in regards to
believers
so
what about non-believers like how does
the kind of i'll just be straight up
with it how does the potential misogyny
of
affect
women if they're non-believers or men's
relationships muslim men's relationships
with non-believing women
muslim muslim men's relationship with
non-believing women
there is no differential in that
as compared to muslim men's relationship
with believing non-believing men there's
nothing in the quran or in the sunnah on
the prophetic tradition that indicates
that there should be any different way
as a general
to how men treat non-muslim women to men
except for those things which are
outlawed by islam
itself for example having intercourse
before marriage or
being alone in a place with a woman now
that can be a muslim woman or a muslim
or a non-muslim woman these are things
islam prohibits because it creates
instability in families it creates
instability in societies and so on
the the the thesis and i'm not sure if
you want to ask this as a separate
question but the thesis that mcgann has
put forward
in her newest book pray is that actually
what you find is that muslim men the
immigration of muslim men to european
countries has increased rape this is
basically it and she mentions in page 33
of that book she says there's an actual
causal relationship
she says that there's a causal
relationship i've read her book the
entire book
and i've seen the data that she puts
forward for the claims that she makes
michaela and she and just go for the
idea
the idea is that muslim and immigration
coming into
european countries causes an increase in
rape that's what each
saying now look
she mentions what is the data that she
mentioned she mentions data from about
five european countries including but
not limited to the united kingdom france
and sweden
now what she then states
is that there's evidence for a causal
relationship in page 33.
what is this data missing michaela this
data is missing
i mean this data has everything going
for it in fact except for the evidence
because
this data does not even have
that these men are muslim men and that
might be a surprise and a shock to you
but this data is about where these men
come from so for instance she cites that
these men come from africa from
subcontinental asia but you will know
and i'm sure your viewers who are clever
people
who have been educated at a minor level
will know that africa is not it's not a
muslim continent the entire continent of
africa there are many muslims in it and
there are many christians in it so the
data is not conclusive in fact it
doesn't even show anything it just shows
that people coming from af there's an
increase of people coming from africa
and then there's an increase also in
rape okay well we tried the same
methodology michaela i actually tried
the same methodology with latin america
and america the united states of america
so people coming from latin america
which are not muslims as you know
when they go into america the united
states there is also a correlative
increase in rape now we can't say just
because there's a correlative increase
in rape and this is a fallacy by the way
that therefore the causation is those
people but even if we did say that
well latin americans are not muslim
latin americans are christians and
therefore the most part very small
muslim minor very very small and
negligible muslim minority and therefore
the whole thesis collapses
she even mentions and she lies through a
mission by mentioning
data from the world health organization
and she is a liar by the way she's a lie
she lied to the dutch parliament she
lies by by a mission by mentioning the
who the only i know the only data that
has uh that the wh has done on rape
and she she mentions certain things
about africa once again there's not even
a muslim continent in its entirety and
subcontinental asia but what she doesn't
mention is that according to the who
that same report that she mentions but
she omits this part
according to the who
that stranger rape is highest in what
they call the high income areas which is
the west so in other words stranger rape
is highest in
europe
well if you want to generalize europe
and america
and canada where you're from so wait a
minute what's going on here the whole
thesis starts to be destroyed and of
course as i've said to you before and
i'll say to you again islam prohibits
pre-marital
pre-marital uh engagements between men
and women how on earth
can you get a thesis that says islam and
she mentions the word course and it said
fallacy causes an increase in rape
for muslim men to non-muslim women where
islam limits it to the highest level
strange rape funny enough according to
the who is lowest in areas which are
most populated by muslim people like the
subcontinental area
of course they say that's because the
cultural reasons of a woman coming out
and all that kind of thing that's their
analysis but that's not their data
furthermore
if it was to do with the jurisprudence
then we know that orthodox jews have a
very similar if not more strict way more
strict
kind of jurisprudential tradition when
it comes to the interaction of men and
women however i will tell you michaela
despite that being the case we don't see
that that is causing any rape within
jewish communities or jewish men doing
that to non-jewish women
she mentions in her one of her
interviews that she does she says that
therefore muslim people need to be made
be taught how to be egalitarian we
believe in a complementarian system
where there's a managerial hierarchy and
the man's at the head of it we do
believe in that okay look we're gonna
lie to you in the households that's we
really that's the only way we can do it
however
she's saying no she's trying to impose a
feminist narrative which you should be
opposed to and your father is already
opposed to when she says that she's
trying to that men that are coming in
from abroad should now be uh kind of
vetted by told by being told what by
being told that they need to believe in
the egalitarian family system now if
that's the case that's not going to
happen with just muslims that should
also happen with christians with
traditional conservative values and it
can happen with jews as well and if
that's the case now she's ex this is a
kind of corrosive
uh
restriction on on human freedom which is
unusual it's a creeping in of
collectivist discourse and it's very
unusual because in other places she
denies that she's a collectivist in
summary therefore i will say that the
thesis is most pathetic
and it's it's is most
uh rejected it i it cannot be and it has
already been refuted by the way by many
many academics but for example
filipovic who's recently written a
comprehensive refutation of this
nonsense that this miserable specimen of
an academic charlatan has written
forward and some reason is being uh is
being taken seriously by people but it
cannot be taken seriously by people this
is basically let me show you something
that michaela says here on the topic
it's basically a rehashing
of
uh it's the rehashing of the jewish
discourses as you can see here the
fascistic the jewish problem you see the
white woman there and then the jewish
man can you see this kind of thing can
you see it i'm not sure if you can see
that this is the kind of thing before uh
i'm not sure if you can see that or not
a little bit closer would probably be
better can you put that a bit closer
please
this is the kind of newspaper article
where the jewish problem the white woman
there's the prize and all the people the
jewish man there bring it back a bit
bring it back
bring it yeah yeah yeah can you see it
wait take it forward a bit
like that
can you see it there's a one down over
there and a jewish man on the side this
is before what happened the pogroms and
whatever happened this is the discourse
she's just
just rehashing a fascistic discourse and
being
academics and clever people we should
you know i'm sure people in the new
conservative movement or of the
alt-right or whoever it is in america
and in the west will be able to see this
what it is it's nonsense it's
academically redundant and it is the
most ridiculous thesis i've ever seen in
my life by someone who has no
peer-reviewed work and should not be
taken seriously by anybody
okay
okay
um let me see we got to one of the
questions i was gonna
so we you addressed one of the questions
so i'll skip that one uh
so let me go
do i want to follow up instead
yeah okay let me follow up and then
we'll get to the rest of the questions
okay so
this is what i've learned and i don't
know whether it's true or not because i
don't know what's true exactly out there
with all the misinformation about
everything
but
this is what i've heard that concerns me
and it's that and then this argument i
think makes sense it's that when there's
an influx of muslim people to certain
european countries and culture starts
changing in those areas
um things like
it's like for instance is this true in
islam that
women who are supposed to have a
guardian
a male guardian
is that your question
yeah isn't that true just so i know to
continue my question so there is
something called a weli
in islam the weli is a male guardian in
certain very restricted contexts so for
example if a woman
travels and it's a long distance some
scholars say she doesn't need anybody to
accompany her some scholars say that she
used to have someone accompanying her
if you were to travel michaela i'm sorry
to put it to you but someone like
yourself
and you had a security guard with you
okay i don't think that's that
diminishes from your independence or
your volitional uh acumen or who you are
as a person i think that just it's a
good precaution to have so it's a right
that a muslim woman has rather than
something which diminishes her value why
because
you know people who are important
require
uh protection and for us we believe that
muslim women are very important so in
that kind of context and in the context
of marriage for example if a muslim
woman wanted to get married some
scholars say the majority of them say
that the the
the guardian should get involved in the
process i should also add that some say
[ __ ] they don't so there's a difference
of opinion here but these are the two
from my mind the two restricted contexts
which guardianship applies apart from
that no
okay okay
good that answer is part of it then the
next one would be like why is it that in
some areas
um women are required to like completely
cover their bodies or in some areas it's
you know their faces are are open um
what's the difference there and what
does that have to do with the actual
well religion
i think this is a view of the religion
it's a minority view but nevertheless
it's a very robust view uh which is that
women should be covered and the majority
view that majority of women in the
muslim world believe
is that the hands in the face should be
should be
can be allowed to be seen but the rest
of it should be covered some say no
actually everything should be covered
and these two views are two views that
muslim people have held for a thousand
four hundred years now it depends on
what view the woman holds what she
decides to do you'll find quite
interesting that the very small minority
of women that do that
and i'm not saying that as a matter of
they're doing something wrong in fact i
think i praise what they do but those
women who do what they do they do it
from their own volition i don't very
rarely from what i've seen have i seen
people being forced to put any carbon
which is the face covering i mean i have
seen people be pressured to put on a
hijab on but not very rarely have i seen
in nepal the idea really is that women
there's a physiological difference
between men and women a sexual
difference between men and women such
that
there should be certain
precautions that are put in place so
that
distractions to an otherwise cognitively
healthy environment
are
limited and that's why you have boys
schools and girls schools in the west
they understand this they understand
that having boys in one place and girls
in one place sometimes it limits the
distraction we just extend that and
there's nothing to say that while having
boys in girls schools for example is
something that should be done and
and that is something that shouldn't be
done what we will say in addition to
that is in fact most psychological
research
including but not limited to
baumeister i think is 2001
and
kathleen who's actually a woman as well
they say that in terms of sexual
difference between men and women that
men's sex drive is completely different
in terms of it's more frequent they say
in the abstract it's more frequent it's
more pressing it's more
severe and so on than women so we do
realize these realities and our religion
it caters for those realities that men
find women immediately more sexually
attractive than what men find a women
find this is something which is pretty
much accepted within the psychological
community in the academic works and so
therefore to avoid uh all kinds of
sexual uh
violence number one
then the quran mentions this so that
they don't get sexually molested or
anything like that and or to also avoid
distraction from the purpose of life
which is to worship one god
the covering is mandated upon muslim
women now as i say covering the faith is
something which some scholars of islam
believe in and some say no actually
covering their face is not something
that is required at all and this is the
vast majority of women accept this
and practice this but in a nutshell it's
because men i know this sounds like a
very basic answer men are different to
women and women are different to men and
those differences are respected those
differences are respected and we have
something else if you want to add if
this as well
in the islamic tradition something
called
which which means
a man's protective jealousy over a woman
so for example if i you know if a muslim
man married a
a woman
they should feel
they should feel uncomfortable
okay and this is the islamic
understanding they should feel
uncomfortable at the fact that other men
are looking at her in a sexual manner
they should feel uncomfortable with that
why because
they should feel as if that's their job
to satisfy sexually and otherwise that
woman
and so
for other men to be feasting on another
woman like that is something we we feel
is uh contrary to the disposition of a
man and something which actually creates
problems later down the line because
well the woman is going to
do certain things and the man's going to
do some things in the family and it's
going to cause these
or unstable families really and so this
is a way by which and through which
stabilities of families can be
maintained and that the muslim people
can keep their honor and in addition to
keeping away from distractions which
will otherwise impede
judgments uh something which is not far
away from the western understanding but
it's extended so the western
understanding we do have girls schools
boys schools girls locker rooms girls
boys locker rooms etc etc who says it
should stop there it's very arbitrary
kind of morality to be honest with you
we say no it should also be extended to
these other areas and we believe that
god the all-knowing or wise one is the
one who laid those foundations down and
if you don't believe in islam in the
quran i understand why someone would not
go with that but if we do believe that
this this book was from god it makes
perfect sense
okay thank you that was interesting
that's a good response okay i've want
one point for devil's advocate and then
i have to get on to the next question
but is it possible that when um
and i'm not saying this for all islamic
men or muslim men but is it possible
that if men grow up learning what you
just said and they go to countries where
women aren't covered
and the reason women are covered in
their country is to avoid sexual
violence
is it possible that that could increase
the tendency towards sexual violence for
women who aren't covered
i will have to say uh it is possible
because i can't tell you it's not
possible
yeah i can only say that it's
hypothetically possible but in order for
that to be uh substantiated it has to be
sociologically verified and i can't say
to you it's not possible because that's
the work of sociologists and
psychologists
unfortunately
as i say it's a good idea has everything
going for it except for the evidence if
people want to affirm such a thesis they
have to go for
a more plausible
theoretical model with a proper
methodology and which is peer reviewed
unfortunately ayan mcgann has done none
of those things or any of those things
and until those things are done
and it becomes something which is
commonly understood in psychological and
sociological literature we have to
remain at least agnostic to this
proposition at this moment we have no
evidence for it
okay
this episode is brought to you by
schwenk grylls schweink grills are
portable american made infrared grills
that get you steakhouse level taste in
about four minutes
the steaks can come out crispy on the
outside but juicy medium rare on the
inside if that's what you like mired
reactions for the win also i haven't
really told anybody this online but did
you know i like my steaks medium well
i want that meat crunchy
these girls don't smoke they're easy to
clean and even come with a pizza stone i
do not recommend eating pizza ever but
if you're going to do it you might as
well do it in the schwank grill
cooking lamb chops though perfection
i would choose these guys over a
barbecue any day hands down right now
there's a special offer over at
shwankgirls.com
just use promo code mp at checkout for
150 off their grill and grill cover but
only with codemp that's
shwankgrills.com
codemp for 150 off it is a sweet deal
especially if you suck at cooking meat
you won't suck anymore with these guys
do you think that there's a link between
muslim immigration in europe and an
increase in sexual violence towards
european women
the answer to that is
yes and there are some caveats i've my
latest book is called pray
and the subtitle is islam immigration
and the erosion of the rights of women
the answer
my uneasy answer to this is yes the
caveat is
not all muslim men
are misogynists and not all muslim men
harass or attack women or treat them
badly
but
there is a minority
and that minority is considerable
and that minority of
very young muslim men have come from
societies
where women are viewed differently from
the way they are viewed in europe and
once they come to europe they start to
behave in ways
that are hostile to women
sexual harassment rapes gang rapes
even syndicates or grooming gangs that
prey on young girls
now what has islam got with any of this
when you talk to religious leaders
muslim religious leaders
what they say is
well the behavior of these men is wrong
but the fact that women are around in
public
uncovered
and by themselves is also wrong so then
they propose
solutions that are sharia based in
europe
that's one
number two
women are divided into those who good
and modest
and those who are bad
and bad women
whether it is
within
islam or within the tribal culture that
some of these young men come from women
who are regarded as bad are regarded as
unprotected
unprotected meaning unprotected by male
guardians
so in that sense what you see is
yeah and i have talked to some of these
young men muslim men in europe and ask
them why is it that you can't if you
behave this way in egypt when you come
to
germany why do you carry on behaving
this way
and
a lot of them have actually
done some reflection on the differences
in societies just say that they explain
the differences and they say
if i behaved this way in egypt or in
afghanistan or iraq i would meet with no
disapproval
the women were targeted they are the
ones who are disapproved of because they
are the ones who put themselves in
trouble
so as you can see there's this big
clash of values or clash of civilization
i don't know what you want to call it
but on the treatment of women it
definitely is a clash of values when it
comes to the values of europe versus the
values of islam
that's very interesting
okay
that makes sense
do you think islam is spreading
particularly over europe
uh the answer to that now is yes and
no
it is spreading
through immigration of course a lot
large number of muslims in muslim
countries are leaving their societies
and
moving to non-muslim societies and i
think europe is in proximity so in that
sense europe is becoming
islamized if you will or there are more
muslim people more muslims who are
living in europe
um but there's also been a huge effort
ever since islam was founded
of proselytizing of trying to get
non-muslim societies to adopt islam
either through persuasion or through
force or through both of those means and
so in that sense it's also spreading
there's a lot
more campaigning for people to join
islam than the other way around
reason why i hesitated when we posed the
question is that i'm also seeing a lot
of young people
today who are leaving islam
and that's a very interesting phenomenon
and in my view it's not talked about
enough
and why do you think that's happening
i think a number of reasons first of all
we've seen in the late 20th century
early 21st century
the
efforts of the radical islamists to use
violence
to take power in muslim societies and to
spread it through violence
you remember outfits like al qaeda and
isis
and these organizations i think have
disillusioned a lot of young muslim
people they forced muslims into a corner
where they pose questions they ask
questions do we really agree with these
things that we're saying they think
about isis when they were beheading
people
and enslaving women and they said this
is sharia law this is what we are trying
to get uh to accomplish and a lot of
muslims were put off by that
and some of those who
went ahead to question
uh whether this was truly islamic or not
many of them were left
feeling
that they couldn't
defend
some of these
actions and they realized many of these
were founded within the faith so i think
there's a lot of disappointment there's
also of course modernity
young people with online social media
even though they may be in muslim
societies or in muslim households
they are exposed
to the modern world i think in ways that
past generations were not
that's having huge impacts
on
young muslim people as well and i think
it takes them to a place of at least
agnosticism if not outright
atheism if that makes sense is islam
slowly taking over europe
well here's the thing uh michaela islam
has always been part of europe we have
to see that first of all the renaissance
according to almost every historian of
science um that spoke spoke about this
issue like for example patricia farah
and uh david lindbergh
but in addition to even orientalists
like thomas uh arnold who wrote the
preaching of islam he's no orientalist
and all those people see that actually
the islamic influence has caused the or
was a trigger at least to the
renaissance and not only that i mean you
have to remember something like this
computer that we're looking at each
other with right now and this i mean a
lot of that was the influence of islamic
science for example ibn haitham who
whose theory on optics was carried over
to the west and therefore through it we
could develop things like cameras so
there is an influence of islam and
always has been an influence of honest
of islam onto europe
and sometimes and most of the time i
would say that's a positive
influence now there are countries in
europe as you know countries like bosnia
and kosovo and albania and provinces
like dagestan and chechnya which are
muslim majority provinces
but despite all of this michaela
according to pew there's only five
percent of people in europe that are
muslim
only five percent there are in my
country where i'm originally from
egypt there are 10 percent of christians
in egypt there's more christians in
egypt a muslim majority country one of
the biggest muslim majority countries
than there are muslims in europe
so there is nothing spectacular
unremarkable about the fact that there's
a muslim minority in europe the
subversion narrative the iron mcgann and
others like her are attempting to put
forward in in order to acquiesce and
duplicate to their
masters in the most servile and most
embarrassing
degrading of ways is something we've
already seen in europe with the jewish
problem that was so called
in the 1930s they referred to as the
jewish problem the nazis who there
thereafter burned six million innocent
jews alive i'll show you another picture
and hopefully this can be shown in
clearer detail look at this
a picture here i'm not sure can you see
this
and we're bringing it closer this is a
picture once again tilt it yes we'll
tilt it it's in the jewish newspaper
bring it down down a bit more
tilt it forward
yeah can you see it there's rats rats
okay now these rats in the jewish
newspaper
were meant to symbolize jewish people
this is the time where it was the jewish
problem now we're seeing the same exact
terminology used iron mcgann who i may
add inspired anders breivik one of the
most
monstrous of terrorists in the last
hundred years he quotes her by name in
his manifesto by name in his manifesto
this man uh who is a nazi basically and
he does the salute you might have heard
of him killed 77 liberal non-muslim
people okay
was inspired and influenced by iron
mcgann iron hersey a terrorist
influencer she is
he was he was looking at the same
literature that people like those who
who would do
caricatures like this of jewish people
were doing and this is the same exact
language we're seeing now instead of the
jewish problem michaela we're seeing the
muslim problem we have to be able to see
this we have to be able to recognize
this so this subversion narrative that
you muslims are taking over europe
although there are muslim majority
european countries turkey is one of the
biggest muslim countries in the world
and half of it is
half of it is actually in europe is it's
physically in europe
istanbul is in europe it's one of the
biggest cities in europe it's a muslim
majority country we're talking about
when we say uh taking over europe so
it's a nonsense narrative that is put
forward by fascistic people apple
polishes for the right wing
like uh mcgann iron mcgann which now
needs to be called out because it's
becoming embarrassing for everybody else
okay
is islam the world's fastest growing
religion
uh it was
and in
some areas it may still be
uh but
right now i would say just given the
sheer number of muslims
who are either adopting other religions
or adopting an agnostic position
or becoming
atheists
i am not sure it is the world's fastest
growing religion now
in terms of
you know religious campaigning
individuals and groups going out to
convert people or to keep people within
the fall of islam
i think that's one question
on which the research has to be updated
but when it comes to birth
i think in that sense
in terms of fertility rates then yes
islam is definitely the fastest growing
religion
okay is islam the world's fastest
growing religion
well according to pew research of course
it is and the reason for that
is that is largely to do with birth
rates because muslim women have more
children than non-muslim women pound for
pound
and that is something that islam
actually encourages quite frankly
polygeny is less of a reason because
it's not widely practiced although it
could be said to be somewhat of a reason
in places like nigeria
where it is practiced in other parts of
sub-saharan africa where is practice
um but there is a growing level of
muslim converts in the west a huge
number of muslim converts in the west
people are becoming muslim from all
parts of the world and the reason why
they're becoming muslim from what we've
seen and we've worked with organizations
that collect these data this kind of
data
is because they are convinced with the
religion of islam they're disillusioned
with christianity they see that
christianity has a slavish type of
morality as nietzsche said slap him on
the one cheek and give him the other
cheek uh nietzsche called it the slavish
morality but obviously that's a verse in
the by the new testament we don't
believe in any of that we believe that
someone slaps you in the cheek you slap
them back we believe that also one god
we've mentioned this we believe in
families we've we've stuck to our
traditional values because it's a strong
religion and solid people have seen that
it actually transforms their lives and
therefore
conversion is actually another reason
why islam is the fastest growing
religion and in fact all of these
reasons combined according to pew
pew research say that in 2100 that islam
will be the world's largest religion of
course another reason is that people are
leaving christianity in droves in in
this country the united kingdom where
i'm from
in 2001 you know we had about 75
christian people in this country and now
2021 although this census data has not
been released it's it's probably going
to be something like 40 that's the
projection of chris that's a deduction
of tens of millions of christian people
in this country why because christianity
has not stood the test of time
the narratives in genesis i remember
even reading your dad's book the maps of
meaning and he had some doubts about
christianity by just reading the genesis
narrative because the genesis narrative
is very much out of touch with anything
that could be considered scientific
and that's another reason the trinity
the the slavish morality the lack of
structure in that religion and so on and
so forth and so forth so people are
leaving christianity which is another
reason why islam is the fastest growing
uh religion
do you mean slavish like um
forgiveness
no i don't well this is a quote from
nietzsche nietzsche
interestingly and i put this on my
twitter he actually had an interesting
sounds of christianity
the fact that you get hit or attacked or
oppressed and that
you don't actually respond
this is almost verging on a pacifistic
notion
this kind of thing is we believe well
nietzsche believed it was a slavish
morality it was slavish it was like a
slave that's how a slave is treated
whereas islam it doesn't say anything
like that at all it says that if you are
dealt with in certain
that the recompense of a sin so if
someone is to harm you in a certain way
is that you harm them in exactly the
same way but whoever is forgiving
whoever is pardoning and forgiving then
there the reward will be with god but
sometimes michaela and you know this
more than anyone else and so does your
father
sometimes kindness turns into weakness
and sometimes
forgiven forgiveness is not forgiveness
especially when you do it with someone
that will harm you again and harm others
again that's why we have prisons that's
why we have that's why christianity
actually had to act like islam in order
to expand in order to be what it is in
other words it had to have a just war
theory it had to have it didn't have
this morality theodosius ii and
constantine and all those emperors of
rome didn't decide to be pacifists they
decided to expand their empires which of
course is something that islam as well
did but something that is within the
fiber of the islamic tradition and
something that christians had to adopt
despite
the the teachings at least
the non-eschatological teachings of
jesus christ in this world so mus in
order for christians to get to where
they are now or where they were before
they had to act in a way which was more
in line with islamic jewish prudence
than it is with this what nietzsche
called the slavish morality of
christianity
okay
next question
in regards to al qaeda and and isis
do you have a response to people who say
well that's not what islam is those are
just like fanatics and they're not they
shouldn't be associated with each other
i do and i think uh what's become very
clear to me over the years is there are
a lot of really good people who are
muslim
and who are
really virulently opposed to the actions
of al-qaeda and isis
the problem
is that when
leaders of al-qaeda and isis
when they invoke the quran or they
invoke the teachings of the prophet
muhammad
those invocations are more consistent
with their actions
than the good muslims who are saying
we reject violence we reject force we
reject intolerance
and uh we embrace
freedom and equality
and so i
think those good muslims find themselves
in a very difficult position my friend
majid nawaz
he says what we should do is we should
make a distinction
between islam and islamism
and if we do that that gives the good
muslim an opportunity to identify as a
muslim and take out of his faith
that what which he needs
and
marginalize
the radicals like the
leaders and members of al-qaeda and isis
as islamists as fanatics
who refuse to separate politics from
religion and so on and maybe that will
work uh
but if you just ask me for you know just
a factual observance i'll say
some of these leaders and their
invocations are consistent with some of
the basic scriptural
uh legacy of the prophet muhammad that's
unfortunate but it's true
okay
isis and al-qaeda yeah now is that is
that
real
islam
yeah well isis and al-qaeda
um well look at exactly what these
people say let me give you the most uh
you know
prominent figure
osama bin laden
bruce lawrence in a book
that was tracking all the things that
osama bin laden states
that in page 141 he states that osama
bin laden one asked about killing
innocent people
and that the quran and the hadith the
quran and the hadith prohibit that so
how come you're doing it
he cited logical
evidence of symmetrical warfare he said
which literally is
he literally said is something which is
known by necessity in other words
they're killing our innocence
so we are killing their innocence this
is his reasoning iron mcgann who
apparently became an apostate because
she iron hersey but her real name is
magan which means refugee somali
language apparently who listened to
osama bin laden and his jewish
prudential readings before becoming an
apostate of islam
she said that she agreed with his it was
with his understanding of islam with his
with his reasoning but osama bin laden
himself admits and this is the book
which can be read in the english
language by bruce lawrence
is saying that this is not because of
the religion of islam it's despite the
religion of islam that we're doing this
it's a logical argument that we're
putting forward of symmetrical warfare
we are we are killing them because they
are we are killing their civilians
because we are killing they are killing
our civilians this is what he is saying
but the quran very clearly states
michaela in chapter 60 verse 8
allah that god does not
forbid you to feel justly with those who
do not try and kill you because of your
religion
or try and kick you out of your homes
and
that you're good with them and you're
just with them that's what the quran
says that god loves the just people in
other words
islam forbids
the killing of innocent civilians
categorically the prophet said
whoever kills a non-combatant
non-believer they will not smell the
fragrance of heaven when innocent people
were killed at the time of the prophet
the prophet muhammad himself he stated
that this is something
he said i am completely disassociated
with this person khalid did which is
killing innocent people the sahabi he
was a companion who was new to the
religion of islam he didn't understand
he said i'm completely disassociated
with it in other words islam is
categorical about the killing of
civilians about the killing of innocent
people non-combatants and so on
now it's a challenge to people like the
hate peddlers like iron megan the hate
peddlers the individuals who are
miserable specimens of academic
charlatans that they are who lie about
the religion of islam to challenge the
referendum
yeah okay um what what is it
is it possible that
i mean you're going to say yes because
like anything's possible so i should
reword that
couldn't
couldn't people
okay you specifically said it's against
the quran to hurt innocent people but if
they're believed to not be innocent then
they could possibly get hurt and i mean
that goes across all religions but
non-combatants
okay
um what do you think the primary
differences are that you've seen between
islam and christianity
the primary differences
primary differences yeah
well i think
the the primary and probably the most
well-known differences is islam was
founded
um
by a man
who
uh
was it was founded in a context
uh
that was tribal
very parochial very small
um
and the man who founded islam
turned it into an empire
so islam
expanded through the use of force
mainly through the use of force
in the early
in the early decades
christianity was founded within an
empire
and
i think from then on
there was this distinction within
christianity this separation
of church and state or religion and
the emperor's realm
and
that's
separation of
religion from politics
in christianity
and the conflation of religion and
politics in islam that's an abiding
difference so that's one key difference
a second key difference
is the figure of
jesus christ who
[Music]
is not a lawgiver and is not seen
he's seen as
god's son
came to the world to save uh human
beings from sin
and there's this uh
i think i'm butchering it but
uh you know
when it comes to some of these religious
punishments
the new testament
is a lot
milder
gentler
than
the body of law should be a law
that islam has and the absolutes within
islam
so throw the fast stone your cast the
fast stone he who has no sin cast the
vast stone
that's not part of islam
so these are i think some very very
interesting differences and they lead to
interesting outcomes
yeah very
what are the primary differences between
islam and christianity
islam believes in one god worthy of
worship okay this god is not a creature
this god is not a man this god is not an
animal this god is not everywhere in the
physical sense such that we can put him
in a jar or put him in the toilet or
anything like that he's not a monkey
he's not a cow he's not in the cow any
of that stuff it's we believe in a
transcendent god that is perfect and
that is worthy of worship the
all-knowing one the all-wise one the
most merciful one by the way the loving
one as well
the loving we believe god is love we do
believe god is love he is the loving one
we believe that he's the forgiving one
that we also have to be loving and
forgiven forgiving but we also believe
god is all just we also believe that god
is
that he can exert punishment on the
people and so this is our conception of
god
we believe in one god worthy of worship
and in addition to that we do not
believe in the trinity we don't believe
in the holy ghost that is also god which
is equivalent to the father and the son
which was which was the development by
the way a roman development in the
fourth century with the cappadocian
fathers if you can read a book like r d
kelly's book it
outlines how the trinity was developed
almost consent consensus on this matter
now that was a trinity the development
of the trinity in rome and they
acquiesced
to
other mythologies which they put into
their religion which is why you find the
trinity even exists like mithraism and
other things i'm not saying it's from
exactly those things but we have
statements from justin mata like for
example a church father who said that
just like you believe in jupiter like
the mythological god we also believe in
the father and the son it's not a it's
not a coincidence michaela that you find
all of these father-son relationships
between mythological gods it's not
coincidence that you have horus and isis
not the not the group but horus and isis
all that mithra and his son or hercules
and zeus whatever it is and then you
have the father and the son and the holy
spirit it's no coincidence the reason
why you find that in christianity is
because it was clearly influenced by
other mythologies that were there at the
time
and so that's one thing we don't believe
in original sin michaela we don't
believe that we are born sinful we
believe in original goodness
why would god the quran clearly states
that one soul shall not be given
responsibility for what another soul has
earned
so why should it be the case
that if adam fell from the tree uh sorry
ate from the tree that i now have the
sin of that we don't believe in any of
that believe in individual
responsibility for one's actions
you know individual responsibility for
one's actions i'm not going to be held
to account for what someone else did
before me so the doctrine of original
sin which is central to the christian
tradition that we are fallen and that we
have sin we don't believe in that we
believe in original goodness the fitra
in addition we don't believe that god
requires a blood sacrifice michaela we
don't believe that god requires a blood
sacrifice in order for him to forgive us
that's exactly what the crucifixion is
he required a blood sacrifice to forgive
us we believe that god is forgiven for
forgiving and that he can forgive us
directly he does not require a blood
sacrifice we also don't believe
that god can die i.e the resurrection
and that god can because god is
we're living
we believe that he's all living never
never dies
when he's dead what was what who's who's
who's holding up the heavens and the
earth who's sustaining and maintaining
the heavens and the earth
so we also believe in the prophet
muhammad which is the final and uh
last prophet which was required in order
to fix these issues which were then
inserted into the religion of
christianity which we believe that jesus
when he originally came he came with the
pure monotheism
he came with the pure monophysical then
after that what happened it was became
tainted and corrupted such that it
required
uh renewal and so when prophet muhammad
came
he basically renewed he back to what
jesus said this is what happened
he he clarified that the message of
monotheism these are the main
differences between christianity and
islam
okay
do you think violence is inherent to
islam
violence is inherent to mankind to
humanity
and
islam
provides
a great deal of justification for the
violent believer to invoke
and to justify and to pretend that
that's the violence he applies is
righteous
hmm
that's really interesting
thank you
that's really interesting yeah okay
do the teachings of islam encourage
terrorism
again because violence is inherent to
mankind
the
individuals want to seek
power
find enough within the legacy of islam
to engage in terror and terrorism
to achieve their desired goals
and so there's plenty in the quran
plenty in the hadith and plenty in the
actions of the prophet muhammad to give
organizations like isis and al-qaeda
permission
moral permission to use
various
forms of violence including terrorism
is violence inherent to islam
right so
violence is inherent to the human
condition
violence is inherent to the human
condition it's inherent to human beings
we've seen it in history
and there's nothing uh inherent about
violence in islam
in fact violence is instrumental in the
islamic discourse it's instrumental i.e
it's a means to an end and not an end
itself because if you look at the verses
which refer to violence
that its permission has been given
to those who can fight in the in the way
of god because they have been oppressed
it's couched in language of
justification if it's couched in a
language of justification that means
that the original condition is not
fighting that is the original condition
that's not fighting it's instrumental
it's a means to an end
since
violence is inherent to the human
condition and history has told this
story
then islam what it comes and does is it
limits
the human impotence impetus the human
impetus for belligerence you see
how does it do it it does it limits the
human impetus for belligerence by giving
ways or just war theory of itself
if you do have to fight do not cut down
trees the prophet told us do not kill
women he told us mccann
it wasn't for her to be killed do not
kill old people he said do not kill uh
you know the monks do not go into these
places in the quran it says that
fighting happens so that you know uh
so that you know beyond was
karoffi or message
that places of worship should not be
harmed and so on
these things are mentioned in the quran
it only takes seconds to look at it it's
not it's an open secret
unfortunately
the quranic discourse has been defamed
and distorted
misappropriated decontextually
understood by academic charlatans like
this miserable specimen who i will not
mention because we know who we're
talking about who has not who doesn't
even know listen michaela she doesn't
even know the difference between a verse
of the quran and hadith of the prophet
as mentioned in one of her
books in i think uh page number 77 in
the book infidel or 301 actually in pa
in the book infidel she mentions that
that
fatah is a verse or something like this
or that the
there's a hadith and she mentions a
hadith she thinks it's the quran she
doesn't even know what's the quran and
what's the hadith
if she doesn't know what's the quran in
the hadith she doesn't even know how to
differentiate between the book
an eight-year-old can do that this
individual if we listen to people like
this who inspire terrorism like anders
berwick and who he mentions her by name
then we will get a distorted
understanding of what islam says clearly
islam is against certain types of
violence and when it does call for
violence or allows violence it does so
in very restricted conditions and it
must be done so the hierarchy and the
state leader and all these kind of
things and if this is something that
someone doesn't believe all someone has
to do is go to the centers of the
islamic power azhar
these big universities which are the
equivalent of the oxford and cambridge
of the islamic world which scholar
believes in what she this woman is
saying this this miserable liar no one
believes in what this this right-wing
far-right narrative
from the muslim world itself
it's only faction groups and ridiculous
people who have political uh agendas and
that unfortunately is islamic terrorists
and also right-wing terrorist influences
like magan
do you think democracy democracy is uh
compatible
like is there a way
oh so i was in um i was in dubai last
year and dubai has gotten
at least from my perspective just having
gotten there has gotten a lot less
strict than it was and you can go to
some areas and you can see oh this is
much more i don't know if conservative
is the right word to use but it's just
much different and then there are areas
where it's like oh no this is where
tourists are now
it's allowed to be more liberal
do you think there's a way for islam to
adapt to the modern world
well first of all what we're seeing is
muslims adapting to the modern world
muslims are voting with their feet
they're coming to europe they're coming
to america they love the rule of law
they love freedom
they they want to take the opportunity
that
countries that are democracies provide
and in that sense i would say
muslims are totally compatible
with democracy because they desired like
all other human beings
the body of sharia law or islamic law is
incompatible with democracy the reason
is because the principle of that body of
law is that god is the law giver
and if god is the lawgiver
then
a believer a muslim believer
a believing muslim
has to
try and
uh
in sync if you will
the thought that
god is the lawgiver
with
a parliament or a congress
or people who are elected to take god's
position and so
that becomes
very very difficult and that is why i
think up to a point organizations like
al-qaeda and isis and so on they were
having
an easy time
recruiting people because they are
saying what the quran says is what we
want this is what the prophet muhammad
did you can't have a democracy in islam
because you are turning human beings
into law givers that's the greatest
possible sin
and so i think if you approach it from
you know
the perspective of the scriptural
framework
then
those two legal frameworks islamic
sharia law with the basic tenets of a
democracy that's incompatible but
muslims millions and millions of muslims
would love to live in a democracy
okay
that makes sense
that's interesting because in in
christianity it says
um
i'm gonna butcher this too but respect
authority right that's part of it so if
you have law givers or people in
institutions or kings it says that
respect them right
right
yeah interesting but i think because in
christianity the separation is accepted
the charge is not the law giver the pope
is not the law giver jesus christ is not
seen as the law giver
and other you know christian scholars
and theologians were not seen as logic
as they may have conducted those
positions
they may have assumed those positions
but the separation is very clear and i
think that will that is probably why
um
you know democracy democracies
and republics
emerged out of
christian culture and why it's a huge
struggle
for something like that to happen within
islamic culture
okay
is democracy compatible with islam
so democracy is used by all those who
use it or i'll say all
maybe
i'll say with for most of those who use
it
instrumentally a communist a socialist
who uses democracy
to vote in a communist party does so
because not because they want to see
democracy enacted necessarily but
because they want to see communism
enacted so in the same or by the same
token those who use democracy
from let's say the muslim
sphere in muslim countries
to implement sharia
they do so instrumentally as well in the
same way as someone would use it to put
socialism or communism so once again
there's nothing peculiar there's nothing
it's unremarkable the islamic use of
democracy compared to other ideologies
that's the first thing i'll say the
second thing i would say is even
christians for example in america they
use democracy in this way
for example conservative christians
sometimes there have been as you know
referendums and other things for gay
rights christians will although they
might not mention this they will vote
against gay marriage for example or
against abortion for example
okay
and they'll do so using democracy so
they're trying to implement christian
values through democracy in the same
kind of way muslim people may use
democracy to put the same kind of values
in this case you know the family values
or something like that so yes but
however what we don't believe in
definitely is that the majority of
people are speaking the objective truth
at all times i mean just because the
majority of people voted for something
it doesn't mean that thing is true plato
made this uh this assessment of
democracy a long time ago when he said
that it's it's not for the ignorant ones
like you know to to to to talk about
things which they're not specialized in
just because the majority of people
think that the earth is flat it doesn't
mean that the earth is flat and that was
the status quo in the wealth history
before people thought the world's flag
so just because the majority of people
say that it doesn't mean that's the
objective truth so we would say the same
thing we believe the objective truth
the objective truth is that which the
all-knowing to all wise says which is in
the quran and sunnah and we have
evidences for that we believe in that we
can prove that
um however
democracy is used instrumentally
and if we're talking about in the
western world then of course it's used
in the same way but in terms of the
muslim world once again it's used
instrumental it's compatible from that
perspective not from the perspective
that we believe that whatever the
majority say is an objective truth uh
which is in any way competitive with the
islamic discourse or the quran
absolutely not yeah this is an important
one okay
and i i suppose you've been working on
this for a good portion of your life but
how do we bring peace for the future
given the fact
there are
but given the fact islam isn't going
away
i mean i i understand the question it is
you know between
how do we bring peace between
muslims and non-muslims
jews christians
atheist agnostics yeah muslims yeah who
refuse to be muslim anymore and who are
threatened how is that i think number
one uh
and i think it's really the key and the
most important point is to have honesty
i've seen a lot of exercise in what they
call interfaith dialogue
where representatives of the various
religions come together and try to
figure out how we can coexist with one
another peacefully
but one of the reasons why i think these
exercises fail is because there's a lot
of beating about the bush
not putting on the table what the key
differences are between these faiths and
those who don't have faith
and i think once we get to the
principles then you can say how can we
get along
and
have rules
have the enforcement
of the rule of law so if there are
muslim
people
coming to non-muslim
societies they have to abide by the
values the norms the laws of where they
come and those societies have to enforce
those laws and marks and values if they
don't then they're going to be faced
with
brute force
and i don't think that's a good starting
point but so far we've seen these
violent confrontations
between muslims and non-muslims and the
way to resolve that i think is by
strengthening
constitutional democracies
to
enforce their laws and their norms i
think the fact that life is changing for
girls and women in europe because there
are immigrants from muslim countries who
make it i think that should be
unacceptable
terrorism
yes
we are free countries and we don't want
to listen in on everyone's conversation
we don't want to become police in
surveillance states
but i think
there has to be red lines
making it very clear
what it
what is allowed and what's not allowed
what's tolerated and what's not
tolerated and then if that's enforced
swiftly and clearly
um i think we will
have
peace until everybody comes around to
thinking
that
they want to live and let live
and when i say everyone i'm talking
about
muslims in particular
okay so for for some of these problems
do you think what would be helpful is
identifying areas of sharia law and just
saying okay this is what it looks like
where
you came from and what you know and then
this is what it looks like here
and are you okay with the difference
that type of thing absolutely
and to spell out that those aspects of
sharia that violates
our constitutions laws
and norms are unacceptable and they will
not be tolerated
and that is an honest forthright
conversation and so the individual
muslim can decide well in that case
maybe i don't want to go and live in
canada or in america or in europe
maybe i just want to go back home
because i want to be a good muslim and
abide by sharia law
you give people choices when you make
these
you know these flaws and norms
transparent
yeah and i suppose that's happening
because
do you think that's happening because
there are areas in the western world
that just aren't
that don't understand sharia law so they
just don't understand the differences
i think number one there yes there are a
lot of places where people don't
understand it it's a different religion
it's alien uh it's too time consuming to
try and dig into it and try and
understand what its origins are what it
means in practice and so on and then i
think there is a second group of leaders
who think it's just a matter of time you
know what maybe now they believe in
sharia law and all that but a few
decades from now everybody's going to
modernize and democratize let's just
give them time now that hasn't worked i
have seen that in europe
and it looks like things actually
instead of
adaptation
you know from
the third world to the first world we
are seeing the opposite trend
where i'll give you the example of women
again girls and women in europe are
adapting to the reality
of having to deal
with
you know harassment
sexual violence
by adopting the same
coping mechanisms mechanisms that muslim
women in muslim countries live by you
know am i going to go out at this hour
am i going to go out of the house all by
myself should i cover or should i not
cover all of these
coping mechanisms
have now made their way to europe and a
lot of women live that way now so that
that's really
that's things going the wrong way that's
backsliding
okay that totally makes sense too
that
those
that that kind of
i guess that that
aspect of the religion could spread
if
you're forcing women to stay safe by
acting a certain way so that they're
seen as less
touchable right basically
but yeah basically that you as an
individual woman you make up your mind
because you think i'm not there's no
point going to the police i'm not going
to be protected there's no point in me
taking the risk with my life and my own
safety
because i know that i'm not this isn't
recognized as a problem yet so these
women are then making a personal
decisions
to
change their lifestyles so that they're
safe in the public space i've talked to
women who said we don't we stopped
jogging
taking the bike walking their kids in
the park
they're women who because they can
afford they've moved from one
neighborhood to a different neighborhood
that doing all of these lifestyle
changes because the rule of law is not
being enforced they're not being
protected from violence by their own
societies that is now backsliding we're
getting we're going back in time to a
place where women made choices
to stay at home
to refrain from working or going out to
the pub or going out to
you know with their friends to sports
dances and so on
because it wasn't safe for them to do
and now you're seeing this sort of thing
coming back and we're tolerating it
we're accepting it and i think that's
wrong it's terrible for women
okay well those are my questions that's
a scary place to
to leave but those were my questions um
ion thank you so much for coming on and
before you go can you tell people where
to find you where to find your books i'm
going to link your books below too and
show notes for anybody who's interested
in reading them
well my latest book is pray
islam
immigration and the erosion of the
rights of women
and it's in bookstores it's on amazon
if you're interested in my views on
islam and whether it can be modified
performed i've written a book called
heretic it's also on amazon
and then my life story infidel
uh
and and that that life story is really
sort of the backdrop of how i come
to adopt the views
that i now have
um so mikayla thank you very very much
for
having me on and once again i apologize
for my tidiness
oh don't worry about it at all that was
great thank you so much i'm just glad i
got the opportunity to speak to you
so so
thanks again thanks again thank you
thank you very much how do we bring
peace to the future so how do we either
like coexist or get along with all these
different
different arguments and different
religions that we have nowadays
well look michaela the thing is the
first thing we need to do is we need to
eliminate aspects of the discourse which
are clearly insightful
i'm not saying through
a culture of sensoriousness
and
blocking free speech or anything i'm not
even mentioning that i'm saying through
academic rigor through fact checking so
when someone like ayan mcgann mentions
all the things that she mentions about
islam and she is not qualified no one
when they when they put her up okay
uh for for interviews like these says
let's vet you let's see what
qualifications of islam you have being
an ex-muslim is not a qualification of
islam
it's not a qualification of islam just
like being an ex-christian is not a
qualification so first thing we need to
do is we need to take information from
right people for people that are
actually vetted i'm not saying that that
has to be me i'm not saying it has to be
any muslim in fact there are very many
non-muslim scholars of islam people like
that are mentioned by magan herself ayan
nagan which means refugee in the somali
language to remind her of our humble
beginnings um that
and of course that's ironic because
she's now against refugees
that people like karen armstrong
that are scholars of islam and have a
completely different interpretation of
islam so why is it the case
that we are fixated on listening to the
conspiratorial nonsense academics of
people like megan and having her on our
shows she has no background in the
religion she doesn't even know what's in
the quran and the sunnah so that's the
first thing we need the first thing we
need to do is eliminate nonsense people
from the discourse not through a culture
of sensoriousness and censoring no
through academic fact-checking and it is
incumbent upon us people like you and
people like me public figures who who
speak on these issues uh to actually
fact-check these people to vet these
people
you know it's not it's not it's not uh
embarrassing to ask her to send her
qualifications her training if you ask
me for that i'll send it to you no
problem it has to be like that the
second thing is
the second thing is we need to realize
it's not that islam and christianity are
at war with each other right now they're
not i mean it's it's there's no crusade
that's necessarily happening at the
moment
if you look at the places where
terrorism has happened the most and if
we define terrorism as state or sorry an
action which is done for politically and
politically motivated actually in the
targeting of civilians
then we as muslims condemn the terrorist
actions
for example the terrorist actions of
hiroshima and nagasaki and dresden and
hamburg and that which is happening to
the muslim people now in the uyghur
concentration camp we condemn all those
things but it's also incumbent upon
individuals from the western discourse
who sometimes can be apologists for such
things
to also condemn those things and i say
to you that it's important for us to
realize that islam and christianity and
judaism has already coexisted historic
historically and contemporaneously
in in spain there was a convavencia in
in much of the ottoman empire there was
coexistence there was
why after the alhambra declaration in
1492
in spain the jewish people migrate to
the ottoman empire they did so because
they were being destroyed by christians
killed by them
forcibly converted by them these things
are clarified in the historical record
and consensually understood by every
historian worth assault
so we have to understand history to
realize that it's not been a case of
it's bleak and there's always been
conflict and i'm not saying also that
it's always been um sunshine and
rainbows michaela i know there have been
times crusades there have been other
campaigns and so on which has been
negative and what we're seeing now the
iraq war the so-called
war on terror terror and so on these are
negative aspects but that's not all
that's happened in a thousand four
hundred years of history so knowing our
history number two so number one we said
to eliminate individuals who are
unqualified ultra crepidarians academic
charlatans like mcgann be miserable
specimen from the discourse not through
sensoriousness but through fact checking
number two is to know the historical
record quite well number three is to
collect our sources from reputable
sources and actually do the research and
finally to realize that if you just
travel i honestly give this advice go
and travel go to ghana go to nigeria
this is a country with 50 muslims if
it's like christian go to countries
where there's a lot of christians a lot
of muslims and you realize that people
are already getting along people are
getting married
muslims and christians are getting
married easily it's it's not something
which is a taboo in many of the world
uh you know and so so this is it's not a
case of this didactic representation
this dualism this binary that she's
created which is a fascistic remnant uh
of something that uh mostly oswald or
even um adolf hitler would say
we need to get rid of this kind of
discourse because it is causing
all kinds of problems and we must
recognize that i must say this to you
it is a collectivist discourse
uh funny enough it's a collectivist
discourse and already you've said uh
everybody you know your father and and i
and mcghan herself has condemned he's
collectivism because you have an
oppressor you have the oppressed who is
the oppressor is the muslims and who is
the oppressor it's a nonsense narrative
which we we must realize is nonsense and
so these are the four steps number one
to eliminate nonsense from the discourse
and education to edify oneself number
two to read the historical record
to to understand that both historically
and contemporaneously that
muslims have gotten along and that they
can get along number three to get your
information from reputable sources to
vet people before you if you want to ask
about medicine you'd go on someone who's
qualified and finally to realize that
this is something that's already
happening and that we can continue
allowing it to happen and just look at
the life of the prophet muhammad he did
not have this life he had a life where
it was clear there was a coexistence
between jewish but he married a jew
himself she was jewish
he lived a life
which was a um
was clearly attempting to reconcile
between people of different religions
and there's so many verses of the quran
to that effect and anyone who tells you
from this point onwards anything other
than what i've said is lying to you
michaela and all i can say is if you
don't believe me then do the research
okay
that was quite an episode thank you very
much for coming on
if if people um want to follow you or
want to find you online where should
they go if you put muhammad hijab on
youtube
that's all they have to do
okay
thanks again for coming on
[Music]
you